>> YOU MUST REMIND YOURSELF
THROUGHOUT THIS ORDEAL OF THE
GOOD NEWS.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT OUR
SELF DISTANCING IS FLATTENING
THE CURVE, SO THE ACCUMULATION
OF CASES ARE SPREAD OUT OVER
TIME.
NOW, YOU WILL STILL HEAR ABOUT
THE GROWING NUMBER OF
INFECTIONS, BUT AS THAT OCCURS,
YOU SHOULD SEE THE FATALITY
NUMBER GO DOWN.
BUT ON THE DRUG FRONT, THERE IS
ALSO PROMISING NEWS.
KNOCK ON SANITIZED WOOD,
RESEARCHERS ARE REPORTING ON A
COMBINATION OF ANTIMALARIAL MEDS
AND ANTIBIOTICS.
THETHEY SAW SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIO
IN THE VIRAL LOAD, MEANWHILE,
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE STRAIGHT FROM
PATIENT’S MOUNTS ARE ATTESTING
TO ITS EFFECTS.
HE HERE IS ACTOR DANIEL DAY CAMP
>> HERE IS WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE
THE SECRET WEAPON,
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
IT IS ALSO THE DRUG THAT
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI CAUTIONED US
ABOUT, HE SAID EVIDENCE THAT THE
DRUG WAS PROMISING AS ANECDOTAL.
THAT IS CORRECT.
IT WASN’T STUDIED, IT IS ONLY
BASED ON PERSONAL ACCOUNTS.
ADD MY NAME TO THOSE PERSONAL
ACCOUNTS, BECAUSE I AM FEELING
BETTER.
>> THAT IS GOOD NEWS FOR HIM,
HOW DOES THE MEDIA RESPOND TO
ALL THIS?
BECAUSE TRUMP HAD TOUTED THE
DRUG ON TWITTER MSN PUBLISHED A
NEWS PIECE WITH THE HEADLINE
"DRUG TOUTED BY TRUMP CAN KILL
IN JUST 2 GRAMS."
A LOT OF THINGS CAN KILL YOU
WITH 2 GRAMS, TRUST ME.
THE MEDIA WHO LOVE TO TOUT THEIR
FAITH IN SCIENCE FLUNK REMEDIAL
MATH, BACK TO THE GOOD NEWS.
IF IF WE CAN TREAT PEOPLE AND
REDUCE MORTALITY EVEN MORE, NOT
ONLY CAN WE SAVE LIVES, WE CAN
ALSO SAVE OUR ECONOMY.
YEAH, IT MIGHT GET SCARY, BUT
HOPEFULLY THE GOOD NEWS SHOULD
SOON OVERTAKE THE BAD.
SO FIRST, WE HAD TO DIVIDE.
FINGERS CROSSED, WE WILL CONQUER
CONQUER.
>> HEY DANA, I WILL ASK YOU
UNDER THE QUESTION.
IT IS SO WEIRD, YOU’RE NOT NEXT
TO ME.
VERY STRANGE.
>> DO YOU MISS ME?
>> I AM ALONE, EXCEPT FOR JESSE
ABOVE ME AS USUAL.
>> TOWERING ABOVE YOU.
>> WE NEED THESE CLINICAL TRIALS
SO WE CAN TELL IF PEOPLE ARE
GETTING BETTER ON THEIR OWN, A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GETTING BETTER
ON THEIR OWN AND YOU HAVE TO
COMPARE GROUPS TO PLACEBOS WITH
THE GROUP THAT GOT THE DRUG, THA
POSES AN ETHICAL QUESTION
BECAUSE IF THIS DRUG IS WORKING,
DO YOU WANT TO BE IN THE PLACEBO
GROUP?
I WAS A NERDY QUESTION.
>> THAT IS A NERDY QUESTION, A
GOOD ONE.
THANKFULLY THERE ARE DOCTORS
WORKING ON THIS, I AM HOPEFUL
THAT IF THIS WORKS THEN WE HAVE
WE KNOW THE DRUG CAN BE MADE.
IF IT WORKS, GREAT.
I WILL BE PATIENT AND WAIT FOR
PEOPLE, BUT I DO WANT TO MENTION
I TALK TO A FRIEND OF MINE THIS
WEEKEND, A DOCTOR.
HE HAS MANY PATIENTS I CALLED
HIM OVER THE WEEKEND, THESE ARE
PRETTY WEALTHY PEOPLE DEMANDING
THAT THEY BE GIVEN THIS DRUG SO
THAT THEY COULD HAVE IT IN THEIR
BATHROOM CABINET JUST IN CASE
THEY MAY BE GET COVID-19 AND
THEY WANT TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU ARE ASKING
YOUR DOCTOR TO DO SOMETHING
UNETHICAL.
SECOND, YOU ARE PREVENTING
SOMEONE WHO MIGHT MIGHT REALLY N
AND COULD GET BETTER.
YOU HAVE A SUPPLY AND DEMAND
PROBLEM WITH THE COST.
LET’S HOPE THAT THIS WORKS, BUT
EVERYBODY IF YOU ARE WEALTHY AND
YOU THINK YOU CAN STOCKPILE THE
STUFF, KNOCK IT OFF.
>> IT IS THAT INCLINATION THAT I
GOT THE MONEY, I WILL JUST THROW
MONEY AT IT AND I WILL BE SAFE.
YOU SEE HOW CHEAP WAS CAUTIOUS
ABOUT THIS, AND TRUMP WAS
OPTIMISTIC.
I ALWAYS FEEL LIKE IT IS TWO
SIDES OF THE SAME COIN AND THAT
DR. FAUCI HAS TO BE THE CAUTIOUS
VOICE AND TRUMP HAS TO BE THE
CHEERLEADER, THEY ARE GOING THE
SAME DIRECTION I THINK.
>> THEY ARE, THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER PROMISING THERAPIES THAT
ARE UNDER DEVELOPMENT.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT SOME, A, AN
ANTIBODY DRUG, IT COULD BE OUT
BY THIS SUMMER.
SOME IDEAS BEING THROWN OUT ARE
THESE TRIALS THAT YOU SHOULD
HAVE MULTIPLE THERAPIES IN THE
SAME LARGE TRIAL, AND EVEN A
SCALE OF MANUFACTURING BEFORE WE
ARE SURE THEY WORK.
SO FOR ALL THE PEOPLE WHO SPENT
YEARS VILIFYING BIOTECHNOLOGY
AND PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES,
THEY WILL SAVE THE DAY AND SAVE
THE ECONOMY.
WE SHOULD BE THANKFUL WE LIVE IN
THIS COUNTRY WITH SUCH A HEALTHY
DRUG DEVELOPMENT REGIMENT.
>> THE GOOD NEWS, I THINK, IS
ALL THE DIRE PREDICTIONS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN HEARING ABOUT DON’T
FACTOR IN THE HUMAN CREATIVITY
AND HUMAN INNOVATION THAT COME
OUT OF INDIVIDUALS, JUST BY SELF
DISTANCING.
YOU BEING FAR AWAY FROM ME IS
SAVING LIVES.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT OF IT THAT
WAY.
IT COULD BE.
BUT I MUST SAY, I AM DELIGHTED
THAT WE SEE THIS KIND OF
POTENTIAL FOR INNOVATION.
I THINK IT IS WHAT IS GOING TO
BE MIRACULOUS.
WE HAVE SO MANY SMART AND
COMMITTED PEOPLE TRYING TO COME
UP WITH ANSWERS, IT IS DIFFICULT
TO TAKE ON A VIRUS.
IF THEY GIVE YOU TAMIFLU, YOU
HAVE TO TAKE IT WITHIN THE FIRST
FEW HOURS OF THE SYMPTOMS.
IF YOU GET SOMETHING NOW, AND
YOU HAVE TO GIVE IT TO PEOPLE,
THERE IS SO MUCH TO BE
DETERMINED.
WHAT DOES WORRY ME IS WHEN I SEE
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED OUT
RECENTLY, WE DON’T WANT THAT YOU
ARE TO BE WORSE THAN THE ILLNESS
ILLNESS.
THERE WERE REPORTS, HE IS
GETTING TIRED OF ALL THE MEDICAL
EXPERTS SAYING YOU NEED TO
SOCIAL DISTANCE, WE CAN’T JUST
HAVE EVERYBODY RUSH BACK.
HE IS RIGHT, IN THINKING WHAT
ABOUT THE ECONOMY?
HOW FAR DO WE GO WITH THIS AT
THE RISK OF HAVING OUR ECONOMY
SHUT DOWN?
BUT I DO THINK AT THIS JUNCTURE,
I HOPE THE PRESIDENT EVEN AS YOU
DESCRIBE IT AS CHEERLEADING, I
HOPE YOU WOULD UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO DR. FAUCI,
TO THE SURGEON GENERAL , AND
OTHERS WHO ARE EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD AT THIS MOMENT.
I THINK THIS IS RIGHT NOW, AT
THIS MOMENT, A MEDICAL CRISIS.
>> JESSE, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THIS?
ARE YOU OPTIMISTIC?
>> I AM OPTIMISTIC, ALSO
REALISTIC.
THIS COUNTRY WAS HOPEFUL AFTER
PEARL HARBOR, AFTER 9/11, AFTER
THE GREAT RECESSION, WE CAN
STILL BE HELPFUL NOW DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT, EVERYBODY ASSESSES RISK
DIFFERENTLY WHETHER IT IS
EXPERIMENT OF DRUGS OR SOCIAL
DISTANCING, THAT DOESN’T MAKE
PEOPLE THAT ARE OPTIMISTIC BAD
PEOPLE, NOT EVERYTHING HAS TO BE
A DOOMSDAY SCENARIO.
WE ARE SEEING POSITIVE SIGNS
LIKE APPLE FOR INSTANCE IS
DONATING 1 MILLION MASKS, WE
HAVE MOBILIZED THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
THEY ARE SENDING A NAVY SHIP
THAT HAS A HOSPITAL INSIDE OF IT
TO NEW YORK HARBOR NEXT WEEK.
AM I SAYING EVERYTHING IS
PERFECT?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WE NEED TO RAMP UP THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT TO GET THESE
MASKS, THESE VENTILATORS,
HOSPITAL PRODUCTS OUT THERE AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
WE NEED MORE TESTING,
DESPERATELY IN THIS COUNTRY.
PERHAPS WE ISSUE WAR BONDS SO
THE CONSUMER CAN BE MORE
CONFIDENT.
BUT LOOKING BACK AFTERWARDS,
THIS IS GOING TO BE OVER.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE OURSELVES IN
A WHOLE NEW WAY.
WE GOT TO COOK OUR OWN FOOD,
SPEND TIME WITH LOVED ONES,
MAYBE EXPLORE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE HAVEN’T THOUGHT ABOUT,
AND WE ARE GOING TO COME OUT OF
THIS OKAY.
>> WHAT DID YOU EXPLORE?
>> THAT IS A PERSONAL EXPRESSION